I think it's indivisible,
surely die,
then you've got it,
or you have.
And every diminution of freedom of
speech diminishes everyone and,
uh,
lessens the currency of freedom of
speech.
But I,
I feel nothing better.
Nice when it's done lightly.
It has to be a controversial statement,
has to be earned.
It can't just be tossed off.
You have to be able to,
you know,
back it up.
And so I would,
I would,
I would urge,
you know,
civilized standards of moderation on
both sides.
It has to be understood that freedom of
speech isn't justice at a decadent
frippery that we,
that we gather around us like all our
other comforts and privileges.
Democracy can't work without freedom of
speech.
It's an absolute cornerstone of
democracy.
So we have to be very responsible about
this freedom,
but there's no giving it up.
Well,
modifying it.
Eaton,
I would say it's a,
it's an offshoot of what solidified on
the political correctness.
And,
um,
I'm a fan of political correctness.
No one ever says I will.
I'm very politically politically
correct,
but in fact it's good that we are,
uh,
not,
not the outer fringe pc,
that and raising the standards about
what can be said and,
uh,
an exclusion was things you could have
said and got away with it a 10 or 20
years ago and now seems discordant and
you know,
who wants to go back to being opposed to
gay marriage.
I mean,
the ease with which that became the
orthodoxy was I thought tremendously
encouraging.
Um,
and the idea that Donald Trump has cost
off the shackles and we go back to being
brutes again,
um,
is a,
is a terrible prospects pc.
His has been an agent for certain sort
of evolutionary acceleration,
uh,
in,
towards progressive ideas.
And I can't.
I think that's been very good.
I mean,
when I look back at my very early
fiction of 40 odd years ago,
I'm,
I'm shocked and made uneasy by some of
the liberties I took that I have set and
he wouldn't take no.
Um,
it,
it doesn't interfere with the freedom of
writers,
political correctness.
It gives you challenges every now and
then you'd have to sort of work grounded
a bit,
but I never resent that.
And I think it's,
it's,
um,
self improvement on a general scale that
we've all responded to.